is a great impressionist so they're like
can you do impressions i'm like
i can do connie chung i guess anything
here's drunk yeah
yeah so i like i would like you know
mike would play maury povich and i would
just go good evening i'm connie chung
you know i mean just kind of some weird
solid yeah
something
and this is gonna sound i don't know if
this is racist or the opposite of racist
but when i first started um dating you
and gardo asked me wait bobby lee from
mad tv i was like yeah the guy who
played miss swan
no comment guys no comment i'm trying to
keep a clean record here
you [ __ ] said that i swear on my life
i thought you played miss one
because i know you played connie chung i
know you played a lot of characters but
i also thought you were the range rover
get the range rover
whatever it's called oh my god
and then he corrected me and he was like
that was alex borstein
but wasn't miss juan supposed to be
asian oh thanks for doing this man i
appreciate you guys
no don't leave
stay here man thank you for being here
i really like you man i really do a lot
hey thanks man oh jeez
so um
that hurts babe
you might as well just said
here's was he on last comic standing no
here's here's how my my brain worked in
that moment it was more like of course
he would play all the asian characters
he's the only asian guy on the show miss
swan is asian of course that's bobby lee
hmm but miss one was an asian she wasn't
no can we see a photo no i know alex
borstein is not but the character the
character was more bjorky
oh like iceland icelandic icelandic
that's what i would have said yeah thank
you so much
no be because when i got on the show
because she had left come on that's so
easy i thought it was oh wow no that's
bjork
yeah
yeah honestly yeah
you know yeah
yeah oh no
turn it sorry what's happening the
[ __ ] heater water it's our water
thing oh my god nothing's gonna exist
[Music]
have you guys always recorded here
um no i used to live in a smaller like
condo
and i used to live like 10 minutes away
from here just right up the street and
then i moved i'm sorry but you look
exactly like both miss swan and connie
okay who's that other lady connie chung
oh there's that connie chung yeah and
that's me yeah that's you to the left
you're on the right this is your first
headshot pretty dead-on that's good
yeah
look at look at me that was so scary
that was the first time
that was the second sketch i ever did at
mad tv that's for you for sure you on
the left yes 100
that was
yeah
and i remember um
lauren dombrowski the producer she
because it was in front of a live
audience yeah and i could it was like a
monologue and i never how much was it
was scripted versus rift
it was pretty much scripted and then the
second pass you can do whatever you want
oh okay that makes sense wait gilbert
not to be um um accused you of being
racist but i don't think the woman on
their right is connie chung i just
realized that
someone on reddit started a whole form
saying this was connie chung but it's
not no it's not connie chung at all yeah
that's not connie chung
who is that i'm the one to the left
that's some random that's connie that's
connie chung
pretty still pretty close though pretty
close pretty damn close but anyway i
remember the producer coming to me and
going
she
grabbed my hand she goes breathe
breathe
because i was like hyperventilating just
nervous oh my it was like i've never
been on a tv set before yeah too many
people and from the deputy into the
cameras and yeah i think at green day
was also playing that they were there
and
i was just caught up in i had a panic
attack and i remember her going you
gotta breathe because you know you and i
we we started in these shitty comedy
clubs right right and we signed up you
did open mics right oh yeah yeah and you
know and that's where we
that's not a school it is a school but
it's like it's not like the groundlings
or second city where you know i mean
there's trains there's guidance yeah
yeah yeah you and i are pretty much like
um
warriors
warriors fighting more drunk people at a
very narrow bar yeah but
there's a set when you first did it
did you were you proud of yourself
uh yeah the first time i did i was 17
and
oh my god so i actually did a comedy
class because i'm a hack but when i was
when i was 17 i did a class in ventura
the ventura harbor comedy who taught it
randy lubus